(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Antes de começar a falar especificamente sobre o
leilão e sobre os procedimentos que você deve
seguir para participar de forma segura, é necessário
que a gente acabe com alguns mitos que
as pessoas espalham sobre o leilão.
O primeiro desses mitos seria o que o
arrematante sempre vai causar um mal a alguém.
É o que eu chamo de arrematante malvadão.
Por quê?
Porque tem muita gente que não tem a
menor noção de como funciona um leilão, que
acredita que o arrematante sempre vai causar um
mal profundo a alguém, que o arrematante vai
sempre ser muito malvado por tirar alguém de
sua casa.
Mas é preciso que você, para participar de
um leilão, não tenha essa imagem.
Por quê?
Porque a gente vai estudar aqui no curso
que existem duas modalidades de leilão e que
existem os mais diversos tipos de dívidas que
podem levar um imóvel a leilão.
Só que muita gente acredita que somente imóvel
popular de gente muito humilde vai a leilão.
E esse é um grande equívoco.
Existem imóveis indo a leilão de todos os
tipos, dos mais populares aos mais luxuosos.
E existe gente que tem condição de pagar
uma dívida, mas se esquiva a todo momento
do pagamento.
Então, na maioria dos casos de leilão de
imóvel, seria perfeitamente possível que o proprietário daquele
imóvel, que é o devedor de uma dívida,
vendesse seu imóvel de forma tradicional, quitasse a
dívida e mesmo assim sobraria um saldo para
que ele pudesse utilizar da forma como preferisse.
Mas a realidade é diferente disso.
Na maioria dos casos, as pessoas esperam até
o último momento, quando não tem mais jeito,
e aí sim o imóvel vai a leilão.
Quando o imóvel vai a leilão, é porque
o proprietário daquele imóvel está devendo a uma
ou mais pessoas.
E, obviamente, quando esse proprietário deve a alguém,
ele está causando, sim, um mal a todas
aquelas pessoas que ele está devendo.
O arrematante não tem nada de malvado.
Então, quando ele participa de um leilão de
um imóvel, ele dá liquidez àquele imóvel.
Ele vai transformar aquele imóvel em dinheiro.
E esse dinheiro vai ser utilizado para quitar
todos os credores daquele proprietário.
Então, várias pessoas vão receber o que têm
direito a partir do dinheiro arrecadado em um
leilão de imóvel, que especificamente é o que
a gente vai estudar aqui no curso.
Veja, existem sim casos que são muito críticos,
que pode ser que você se depare com
um imóvel, com alguém muito idoso sendo proprietário
ou residindo naquele imóvel, uma pessoa que não
tem qualquer possibilidade de, naquele momento, quitar as
suas dívidas porque pode estar muito doente, ou
porque pode estar desempregado e não consegue se
inserir no mercado de trabalho, ou alguma outra
situação do tipo.
E, nesse caso, é sua opção ficar de
fora daquele leilão caso você não se sinta
confortável para dar um lance naquele imóvel.
E tudo bem, existem leilões de imóveis todos
os dias.
Quem quer participar de um leilão, efetivamente, escolhe
o leilão que vai participar.
Uma das análises mais importantes antes de entrar
em um leilão, que nós vamos estudar aqui
no curso, é verificar quem está ocupando aquele
imóvel.
Então, quando você verifica quem está ocupando aquele
imóvel, se você se deparar com uma situação
dessa, que você considere muito grave, que você
acha melhor ficar de fora, você pode ficar
de fora sem problema algum.
Existirá sempre um próximo leilão.
Até mesmo é possível que tenha um leilão
naquele mesmo dia que te interesse.
Aqui, eu também já queria afastar um mito.
Tem muita gente que acredita que idade de
uma pessoa, seja uma pessoa muito idosa ou
criança, pode atrapalhar a desocupação de um imóvel.
Isso não é verdade, isso é mais um
mito que se espalha quando o procedimento do
leilão segue corretamente o que diz a lei,
não existe nenhum empecilho para que ocorra a
emissão na posse em favor do arrematante, ou
seja, para que o arrematante tome posse do
imóvel que ele arrematou.
Mas, se você se deparar com uma situação
que você acha que é melhor não participar,
também é uma opção sua e tudo bem.
Fique de fora daquela e escolha outro leilão.
Isso não vai trazer nenhum prejuízo para você.
O segundo mito que as pessoas mais acreditam
quando a gente fala sobre leilão de imóvel
é que existe no Brasil uma máfia dos
leilões.
Muita gente acredita que só é possível arrematar
o imóvel em leilão se você for amigo
do leiloeiro, amigo de um juiz, ou até
mesmo se você tiver um contato dentro de
algum grande banco.
Isso também não é verdade.
Os leilões são públicos, qualquer pessoa pode participar.
Existem casos muito específicos de restrições às pessoas
que não podem participar.
Nós vamos ter uma aula específica aqui nesse
mesmo módulo 1 sobre quem pode participar de
um leilão e você vai ver que essa
restrição é muito específica e para casos específicos.
Nem mesmo existe uma restrição geral que proíba
alguém de participar de todo e qualquer leilão.
Então, como o leilão é público e aberto
a qualquer interessado, basta que você se habilite
para aquele leilão que você poderá participar do
leilão.
Não precisa ter contato com ninguém.
Esse argumento de quem fala que existe uma
mafia de leilão nem mesmo tem qualquer embasamento.
A gente vai ter uma aula específica aqui
no curso para estudar quem são os leiloeiros
e qual é a forma de remuneração de
um leiloeiro.
Mas eu já vou adiantar que o leiloeiro
recebe uma remuneração a cada leilão que ele
realiza.
Essa remuneração é uma remuneração média de 5
% do valor de cada arrematação.
Então, quando alguém sustenta que existe uma máfia
de leilão, que só um amigo de um
leiloeiro poderia participar de um leilão realizado por
ele, qual é o fundamento disso?
Porque se o leiloeiro é remunerado em cima
do valor final da arrematação, tudo que o
leiloeiro mais quer é que em todos os
leilões que ele realize tenha o máximo de
disputa possível.
Porque quanto mais disputa existir por um imóvel,
maior vai ser o valor final da arrematação
daquele imóvel, maior vai ser o valor da
comissão do leiloeiro.
Então, pelo contrário, não existe essa máfia dos
leilões.
Os leiloeiros hoje em dia utilizam o máximo
de publicidade que eles podem dar para todos
os leilões que eles realizam.
Então você vai encontrar leiloeiro fazendo anúncio em
rádio, em todas as redes sociais que existem,
em sites especializados em venda de imóveis, porque
tudo que o leiloeiro quer é que tenha
o máximo de competição em todos os imóveis
que ele está levando a leilão.
Então fique na sua mente também que isso
de máfia dos leilões não existe.
Você pode perfeitamente participar de qualquer leilão de
seu interesse sem conhecer ninguém que esteja envolvido
diretamente naquele leilão.
E aqui já vou deixar uma ressalva, que
eu mesma nunca tive contato pessoal com nenhum
leiloeiro.
Eu participo de leilões online, então o procedimento
é todo online.
A gente vai estudar aqui numa aula específica
que você não precisa encontrar em momento algum
com aquele leiloeiro para que você realize todo
o procedimento de participação de um leilão online.
Então acabando com esses mitos que cercam o
leilão e que são difundidos em grande maioria
por pessoas que não têm a menor noção
de como funciona um leilão, vamos passar então
para a nossa primeira aula de conteúdo prático
sobre os leilões de imóveis.